Shanda is with us in dayton ohio hi
Shonda how are you hi Dave I'm great how
are you better than I deserve what's
right thank you for taking my call sure
I am calling I need a Dave Ramsey pep
talk okay my husband and I we started
the financial piece about three or four
years ago attended one of the classes
and we've were cash flowing everything
College braces car you name it we're
cash flowing it sold an expensive
vehicle that we had in bought two used
vehicles and I feel like we're still not
getting anywhere we have so much to cash
flow that we're not getting anywhere on
our two used vehicles we have a credit
card
what's your household income between 120
and 130 thousand how much is your house
payment 1,200 a month and how much are
your car payments
both are 250 a month each yes okay so
500 there and 1,200 mm-hmm and how much
other debt do you have we have well like
I said we're cash flowing College so how
much is College where is that it's just
at a local Community College and it's
about 1200 every semester so every three
or four months so it's 400 bucks a month
okay yes we're cash flowing braces which
is about 1500 over three years
um no two years okay so that's fifty
bucks a month yeah yeah okay and then we
have a Discover card for six thousand
this is all you have that's it you eat
out too much and you don't have a
written budget okay am i right no we I
know we eat out too much do you have a
rain budget um I have a budget you don't
have a written budget where every dollar
has a name a zero-based budget like we
teach you to do and you and your husband
sit
and agree where every dollar is going to
go before the month begins on paper on
purpose and then you stick to it you're
not doing that
well I do and I'll tell you I do have a
budget first of all my husband is
listening and he doesn't do the budget
with me so you may want to tell him to
get on board get on board okay thank you
I have a budget that I had you know like
the envelope system every every two
weeks when we get paid I sit down I
divvy up everything into the envelope
you didn't listen to what I said okay
that's not a budget that's not a budget
what I told you to do is you've got to
sit down with a piece of paper or a
budget form do you have a copy of the
Total Money Makeover book yes we do have
you been in Financial Peace University
yes you have did he go with you did he
go with you he did go with me and we
have also sent my daughter who just
graduated high school we you fought her
we did flunk you go back through because
you did not do the written budget the
way we teach you the whole time you were
in that class and you're still not doing
it you went and watch the videos and
laughed and learned a few things but you
didn't apply because here's the front
here's the thing let me tell you what
happens in Financial Peace University we
know all the statistics because we've
had four million families go through it
okay
so here's what happens the people who do
the written zero based budget together
as a couple where every dollar every
month is written down and they stick to
it exactly the way we teach are the ones
that have 90% better success the people
that don't do any budget at all half of
them drop out and the ones that do a
half but budget which is what you're
doing we have a frustrating level of
success and feel like crap Here I am I
went through this class I still make
$120,000 a year and I still have
reasonable house payment and I still
don't feel like I'm getting traction and
you're a classic case study of what we
run into so you guys can go back through
the whole class for free it's a lifetime
membership you're allowed to go back as
many times as you want go back through
it again okay and this time learn to do
it together and if your husband is
listening sir
here's my advice to you rather than
buying your wife flowers as an act of
love sit down as an act of love and help
her lead this household through the flow
of money because you feel like you're
carrying all the responsibility when he
doesn't help correct and it gets
tiresome correct and I it's an act of
servant leadership on his part to love
his lot wife well by sitting down with
her now you may be the more
administrative of the - are you yes
you're the detail nerd more than him
okay that's correct then you've got to
do this full written budget first that
you think it is and go back and listen
to the you've got the CDs don't you we
do you listen to everything you listen
the CD on budgeting tonight just plug it
in when you get off the phone plug it in
listen to it again and then find a class
go back through it so I'm not I'm not
charging you anything go back through
it's all free and but get it where it's
written down and then get and then when
all I want him to do is to spend 30
minutes with you a week looking at the
budget and helping you make the
decisions if you make the decisions and
carry the weight together then when
Shonda writes the checks
she's just being the accountant but
she's not having to be the CEO of the
house okay and right now you're having
to carry all the weight of the of the
responsibility the household and do the
administrative work but when you two
agree in pinky swear and spit shake on a
detailed written plan and you make your
weekly adjustments as you go along then
your your respect for him is going to go
up it's an act of love on his part it's
a way you communicate about your future
and then you when you write the checks
you're not making decisions then you're
just doing what the Budget Committee
told you to do mm-hmm and you're a
member of that committee it happens but
it's like my court Mike I've got a
controller here that does our payables
and so when we do payables she doesn't
sit and fret over those numbers they're
just numbers and she's just filling out
checks all the decisions were made by
someone else marine she doesn't carry
the weight of that and so I want you
guys to go back through and do that
written plan because you're making
enough money to get headway
absolutely and you're not you're still
spinning your wheels and it's
frustrating do you and I don't blame you
so used
I said eating out too much its lifestyle
probably but I think what'll happen is
when you get on a written plan and the
two of you together say alright we're
going to do this we're going to get
gizelle intense we're going to roll up
our sleeves we're going to gather knock
out these debts we're going to list
these debts smallest to largest pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and attack the little one
we're gonna get those budget forms from
Financial Peace University back out
we're going to make copies of them we're
really going to do this as if we were
hired by someone for $100,000 to fix
their budget because right now you got
$100,000 coming in your house and
$100,000 going out of your house and you
got nothing to show for it
so I'm getting ready to give you
$100,000 raised in return for doing this
on paper on purpose you're gonna win
Shonda and I want you to call me back
and tell me how this is working in six
months tell me it's working and call me
back with your debt free scream - this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you